et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec pascal drouhaud président de
l'association lacq francs et spécialiste
de l'amérique latine
bonsoir pascal drouhaud merci d'être
avec nous sur arte france on le voit
l'amérique latine commencent à sortir de
ce calvaire de cette crise sanitaire
c'est un des continents qui a été le
plus touché par le virus après l'europe
il voit le bout du tunnel je ne crois
pas que il voit le bout du tunnel mais
en effet la pandémie a des conséquences
à long terme
l'amérique latine on le voit dans votre
reportage est entré en fait dans cette
phase de confinement de mesures de
prévention de l'expansion du virus d en
fait le mois de mars dernier
dès le mois de mars et avril et c'est
bien pourquoi aujourd'hui la crise
sociale est aussi grave parce que six
mois après l'amérique latine connaît des
pics de pandémie 7 millions 6,2 cas à ce
jour près de 280 mille décès et on voit
bien que les pays on l'a bien vu dans
votre reportage notamment des économies
aussi importante que le chili ne sont
pas pas justement sorti de la crise
sanitaire mais la crise économique et
sociale devient désormais tellement
inquiétante qu'il est indispensable de
commencer à des confiné en fait les pays
ceci étant n'oublions pas que le
continent latino-américain ses 54 % de
l'économie informelle
54 % de population active qui
travaillent dans l'économie informelle
et qui ne bénéficie donc pas par
définition de toutes les aides sociales
que pourraient apporter les états mais
là aussi on est dans le coeur du
problème c est à eux ont des budgets
contraints parce que les recettes
fiscales ne sont pas extrêmement
importante et donc ces pays se sont
concentrés sur des aspects particuliers
notamment la le domaine régalien
la sécurité notamment les forces armées
est donc évidemment tout ce qui touche à
l'accompagnement et le social à la
protection sociale a été le point faible
en général durant ces dernières années
et le lapin démis révèle ses faiblesses
et révèle donc aujourd'hui ce qui se
révèle aujourd'hui à travers une crise
sociale économique importante mais
également politique
on le voit à l'écran évidemment cette
situation de tension sociale et de
manque de protection sociale
s'accompagne inévitablement de tensions
politiques la raison de ces tensions
dites moi si je me trompe pas vous
parliez d'un confinement extrêmement
long ça a été le cas notamment pour le
chili mais pas pour le pas pour le
brésil par exemple au chili à lui
imposer des mesures drastiques des
grâces ticket d des répressions assez
importants pour maintenir les gens à
domicile contrairement au brésil donc
est ce qu'il n'ya pas des géométries
variables néanmoins alors oui d'abord un
l'amérique latine elle est diverse
l'amérique latine les caraïbes ce sont
33 pays de 33 pays 33 réalité différente
ça ne faut surtout pas considérer
l'amérique latine comme même bloc
ce serait une erreur primo secundo vous
le savez le brésil est un état est un
pays fédéral donc les confinements ont
eu lieu au brésil
ils les mesures ont été prises par les
états je pense notamment à sao paulo
avec des tensions sociales avec l'état
fédéral avec le pool le coup brasilia et
le président fédéral brésilien mais il
ya eu des mesures fortes qui ont été
prises notamment à sao notamment à rio
et dans d'autres états du brésil qui lui
aussi est d'où là aussi des tensions et
d'un débat politique extrêmement vif et
vous avez raison de le rappeler ces
dernières semaines une panière ces
derniers mois entre l'état fédéral et
les états qui composent le pays du
brésil mais en fait tous les pays latino
américains on était en fait les bons
élèves au tout début de la pandémie en
masse
ce avril locaux vides n'était pas arrivé
en amérique latine mais ils ont appliqué
par mesure de prévention des mesures
donc d'aider des mesures très strictes
mais qui sur la durée évidemment ont des
effets absolument dramatique
je rappelle que c'est aujourd'hui près
de 37% de la population latino
américaine nous parlons de plus de 230
millions de personnes qui vivent dans la
pauvreté ou dans l'extrême pauvreté
aujourd'hui qu'elles sont près de 40
millions de personnes pendant qu'ils qui
sont entrées dans la pauvreté depuis le
début de duke au vide alors l'europe et
soutenu on l'a vu financièrement qu'en
est il de ces pays
quel quelles pourraient être les
conséquences politiques et économiques
alors vous parlez de l'europe donc en
effet la crise révèle la faiblesse de la
solidarité régionale
il n'y a pas de plan de relance
régionaux en amérique latine alors même
que laisserait les structures régionales
existent l'alliance du pacifique
notamment qui rassemble le mexique le
chili la colombie le pérou des économies
qui faisait partie des plus importantes
du continent
par exemple nous pouvons parler aussi du
mercosur du sica en amérique centrale et
pour autant où sont ces structures
aujourd'hui le et notamment à travers la
mise en place de plans de relance elles
ne sont nulle part donc c'est ça la
carence en fait et le point de faiblesse
en amérique latine
c'est un continent qui était émergents
mais sept mois après le début de la
pandémie l'émergence paraît bien
lointaine et on sent bien que le
continent est en train de sombrer dans
des tensions qui leur en bois aux
décennies extrêmement difficile des
années 70 80
donc oui les plans des plans de relance
pourrait être nationaux mais en effet on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui l'absence
régional et est très forte
merci beaucoup pascal drouhaud d'avoir
répondu à nos
et s'ils ont ce soir sur rtl france